la baguette de pain en france c'est un
symbole important et pas que cela c'est
le quotidien c'est la vie de tous les
jours depuis ce matin elle coûte 1 franc
tout rond on ne vous a pas rendu les
cinq centimes habituel chez le boulanger
du quartier ou du village un franc pour
250 g tous les autres pain augmente
partout en france à compter
d'aujourd'hui également de 10 centimes
l'unité quel qu'en soit le poids
pourquoi cette augmentation le pain
français mérite t'il toujours sa
réputation y compris à l'étranger une
enquête de jean françois robin et
la baguette à 1 franc dans la région
parisienne voilà qui va bien sûr
simplifier les problèmes de mener mais
voilà aussi qui nous permet aujourd'hui
de calculer la part de chacun dans le
prix du pain alors par exemple 16 % 16
centimes c'est la part du producteur
remboursant trois centimes la part des
frais de stockage 6 centimes la
transformation du blé en farine 2
centimes les frais de transport divers 8
centimes ça c'est pour le fisc ce sont
les taxes et puis reste 65 % 65 centimes
pour le boulanger qui se taille
apparemment la part du lion du suppose
il ya beaucoup de frais vont produire
cette vague exactement heureux parce
qu'il ya quand même tous les
amortissements les financements les
investissements naturellement et les
charges sociales et tout ce qui se
branche de su quoi en la baguette
aujourd'hui à 1 franc est ce que c'est
rentable on sait pas encore exactement
ce qu'il faudrait cette augmentation est
tout de même appréciée car elle ne
s'accompagne pas d'un relèvement du prix
de la farine ce sera pour la prochaine
fois en août probablement à propos de
farine il ya quelques mois les meuniers
avait lancé un cri d'alarmé au congrès
des producteurs de blé à biarritz au
mois de juin la question était
d'actualité le pain français est en
danger car les céréaliers produisent des
blés à fort rendement mais dont la
farine est impropre à la fabrication du
pain depuis les choses ont évolué et
semble-t-il favorablement la commission
de bruxelles s'était mis de ce problème
le conseil des ministres de
l'agriculture des neuf s'est penchée sur
ce problème et en corollaire de cela la
commission va proposer au prochain
conseil des ministres
semaine prochaine une nouvelle
hiérarchie de prix de blé blé destinées
à l'alimentation animale et blé destiné
à la panification
mais la baguette sera sauvé la baguette
sera sauvé
les producteurs sont engagés dans cette
voie de production de qualité non
seulement pour la meunerie française
mais dans tous les acheteurs étrangers
les agriculteurs se sont aperçus que
certains blé qu'ils employaient qui
donnait de bons rendements
étaient moins bons pour le pain oui ils
le savaient et la campagne d'information
nous avons mené à sensibiliser les
producteurs au fait que si nous ne
pratiquons pas une politique de qualité
nourrissions de voir réduit nos
débouchés notamment envers l'euro
[Musique]